[موسيقى]
في غرفه صغيره يسكن محمد وعائلته مع
والديه وسط بيتا لا تتجاوز مساحته 100 متر
ويشغل غرف البيت الاخرى اخوانه وعائلاتهم
ما يجعل الحياه في البيت خانقه ومحرجه
دائما ان مشاكل على طول مشاكل انا واخوي
لانه
غرفه عقبال غرفته بالضبط ودائما مشاكل من
ورا صغار ومشاكل وضغط يعني الواحد الله
يعينه براوه من الشغل تعبان ومش حمل مشاكل
وبرجع بلاقي مشاكل بالصبح مشاكل وفي الليل
مشاكل برضو هذا كله انا مليش ذنب فيه يعني
نشدناهم كتير وزاره الاسكان يعني عدد سكان
كثير احنا ايش ذنبنا احنا
[موسيقى]
يحصل محمد على قوت يومه من بسطه متواضعه
لصنع القهوه والذره على شاطئ بحر غزه وهو
دائم البحث عن منزل اخر اكبر ولكن ازمه
السكن وارتفاع الاسعار وضيق الحال تجعل
بحثه بلا جدوى عدد سكان البيت اكثر من 15
نفر مع الصغار
اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد
وضع الاقتصادي صعب مش قادرين نعمل فيها اي
حاجه حتى انه مش قادر احط نايل فوق حتى
اعلق المطر انه يخش جوا على البيت
انا طلعت حاولت اتاجر بره لقيت اقل ادنى
سعر الايجار 350 شيكل وانا ما قدرتش ادفع
350 شيكل الوضع الاقتصادي كيف انا طبيعه
شغلي بشتغل على الكورنيش بحر غزه 15 شيكل
وخميس وجمع عشرين شيكل اوقات بروحش
عشان اوفر السبع شيكل المواصلات
على فكره وحياه اللي خلقك عشان احنا نقلت
الموت احنا مش عايشين والله لولو احنا مش
عايشين اصلا
تشهد غزه نموا ديموغرافيا متزايدا وسطا
محدوديه الامكانات المتاحه ليصل عدد
السكان الى مليونين و350 الفا تقريبا في
القطاع في مساحه جغرافيه صغيره تتناقص
اراضيها الزراعيه يوما بعد يومه بسبب
الزحف العمراني وتمدد العائلات ما يجعله
من اكثر الاماكن عشوائيه وكثافه سكانيه في
العالم
[موسيقى]
يعيشون على ارض صغيره مساحتها لا تزيد عن
365 كيلو متر مربع اي ان متوسط المساحه
للفرد هي 150 متر مربع هذه المساحه الضيقه
هي مساحه لاقامه انشطه السكن والانشطه
الثقافيه والاجتماعيه والرياضيه والسياحيه
والتجاريه وهذه المساحه غير كافيه عملنا
على العديد من الاجراءات
لمعالجه ازمه الاسكان بدايه
تطوير انظمه الابنيه الموجوده
حيث سمحنا باضافه ضابط اضافي على المباني
الموجوده وهذا من باب التوسع الراسي اضافه
الى تطوير العشوائيات
وايضا تعزيز المناطق الحدوديه
[موسيقى]
مقبره الشيخ شعبان هي الاقدم في مدينه غزه
اتخذ منها عشرات العوائل ملاذا ومهربا من
ازمه السكن الخانقه في القطاع التي باتت
ازمه حقيقيه فالحاجه مستمره والمتوفر ثابت
لا يتغير من مساحه لعدد الاراضي المتاحه
للسكن مع عجز في الوحدات السكنيه بما
يقارب 100 الف وحده سكنيه
تحت ظلال الاموات يلعب اطفال بيوت الصفيح
غير مدركين لحجم الماساه بعد هنا تتمثل
حقيقه مزاحمه قبول الاموات حيث تعيش عائله
كحيل المكونه من سبعه افراد في مسكن
متواضعه بالطرف الشرقي للمقبره بني البيت
على قبري شخصين مجهولي الهويه حتى صار
جزءا من اساساته الظروف الاقتصاديه الصعبه
فرضت على العائلات التاقلم مع تلك الحياه
طالب بيت انا مش اقدر انه بيت يتويني
ويتوي اولادي واسلم هذا البيت للاوقاف
وارحم القبور من العذاب تبعنا لانه القبور
تعبوا اصلا اقول لك يخلف عليهم انهم
القبور استحملونا يخلف عليهم البني ادمين
الطيبين اللي برا ما استحملوناش هم
استحملونا يمكن احنا نرحمهم لما نطلع من
هنا من اولادنا عليهم
شويه صغيره مرضى نفسيين كلهم بالكامل لانه
هذا مش حياه
يعيش في قطاع غزه نحو اكثر من مليونين
نسمه على مساحه لا تزيد على
365 كيلومترا مربعا ويقسمون على اربعه
واربعين تجمعا سكنيا بمعدل كثافه تقدر
بسته وعشرين الف فرد لكل كيلومتر مربع في
المدن وخمسه وخمسين الف نسمه لكل كيلومتر
مربع في المخيمات وهذا يشكل خللا في نمط
الاسره الفلسطينيه في ظل توزيع عشوائي
للسكان والاعمار والاراضي من قبل السلطات
في غزه حيث يتركز في المنطقه الغربيه
الساحليه وهي منطقه زراعيه مهمه ومن
الافضل ان يكون السكن والاعمار في المنطقه
الشرقيه لانها منطقه قليله المياه ولا
تصلح للزراعه ما يهدد سلامه الامن الغذائي
في غزه جزء من هذه الاراضي ما زالت اراضي
الزراعيه ليس هناك اراضي سكنيه بشكل كبير
يمكن ان انبه حاجه السكان اضافه الى ذلك
نحن نتحدث اساسا عن عجز في الوحدات
السكنيه في قطاع غزه وحاله الفقر وحاله
البطاله التي يعيش فيها سكان قطاع غزه ادى
الى ظهور حاله من العشوائيات في بعض
المناطق المتاخمه للمدن والقرى وبلدات
الفلسطينيه وبالتالي بدانا نرى
حاله اسكان عشوائي قائم على اسكان مؤقت في
بعض الاسر المحتاجه والمعوزه في هذه
المناطق وفي غياب واضح من قبل الجهات
المسؤوله عن وضع استراتيجيه لمعالجه ازمه
السكن في قطاع غزه وازمه الاسر الفقيره
والبطاله والفقر
لدينا احتياج
للوحدات السكنيه يزيد عن 100,000 وحده
سكنيه
واحتياج سنوي طبيعي
قرابه 14 الف وحده سكنيه نتيجه التزايد في
عدد بشكل طبيعي اضافه الى ذلك هناك هدم
متكرر من الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لمنازل
المواطنين والامنين هناك هدم للابراج
السكنيه لم يتم اعاده اعمارها حتى الان
هناك الفين وحده سكنيه لم يتم اعمارها حتى
الان نتيجه العدوان المتكرر على قطاع غزه
الحروب مع اسرائيل والانقسام الفلسطيني
الداخلي افضل الى زياده الازمات السياسيه
والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه في القطاع وجعل
من غزه مدينه معزوله عن العالم
مشكله غزه كثيره وباتت عصيه على الحل
سكنوا العائلات وسط القبور واحده منها
التي ستكون لها تداعيات خطيره على مستقبل
الاطفال نفسيا واجتماعيا
مخاطرها كتير
زي ما انتم شايفين
قصه صعبه بس خلاص اقلمنا الموضوع
في الاوقاف بنطلع رزقه لانه احنا ساكنين
اموال بنشرب وبناكل وبنتغسل على الاموات
فربنا كيف بده يجازينا ربنا قال ما فيها
رزقنا اول حاجه
عشان هيك احنا
ملنا الحكومه وزاره الاوقاف انه تشوف لنا
حل
لانه احنا سكنتنا بالسكنه مش احنا خلاص
خلص الدور احنا تبعنا احنا لاولادنا ممكن
لو مثلا يجي عريس للبنت ويلاقينا ساكن في
المقبره ممكن ما يرجعش وكتير صارت الا غير
واحد من من ديرانك ياخذ البنت
[موسيقى]
خبراء التنميه والاسكان يرون انه من
المتوقع ان يزيد عدد سكان القطاع باكثر من
الضعف في غضون الثلاثين عاما المقبله
ليقارب خمسه ملايين نسمه وسط شح في
الاراضي غير الماهوله التي بدات في النفاذ
فهل سيكون اعمار البحر حلا من الحلول
المستقبليه
التوسع في البحر هو ضمن الحلول الابداعيه
التي تنتهجها العديد من دول العالم ذات
المساحه الصغيره والضيقه مثل قطاع غزه
ولكن نحن في قطاع غزه المحاصر هناك نقص في
الامكانيات ونحتاج الى العديد من الخبرات
اللازمه من اجل وضع حلول في ردم البحر
سيما اننا نواجه نتيجه التغيرات المناخيه
نواجه تاكل في الشاطئ من يعني اقصى الشمال
الى اقصى الجنوب
[موسيقى]
الحروب والبطاله المتفشيه بين الشباب
وغياب التخطيط ووضع الخطط الاستراتيجيه
الفاعله لحل مشكلات قطاع غزه ومنها ازمه
السكن كلها كانت لها تداعيات خطيره على
حياه المواطن الغزاوي في غياب واضح من قبل
الجهات المسؤوله عن وضع استراتيجيه
لمعالجه ازمه السكن في قطاع غزه وازمه
الاسر الفقيره والبطاله والفقر وبالتالي
هذا هو الذي فاقم من ظهور هذه المشكله
وباتت على السطح بشكل كبير نحن نتحدث
اليوم ان الشعب الفلسطيني تقريبا ثلث
الشعب الفلسطيني او بالتحديد 41% من سكان
قطاع غزه هم دون ال15 وبالتالي من المتوقع
ان تزداد ازمه السكن بعد خمس او عشر سنوات
بشكل كبير جدا ان لم يكن هناك مخطط واضح
ويتم ضمن اسس علميه لم ازمه الاسكان في
قطاع غزه انا بتوقع انه في السنوات
القليله القادمه الازمه ستكون اكبر واكبر
وبالتحديد في قطاع غزه
الجيب الساحلي الصغير يعاني من تنامي
الكثافه السكانيه بشكل مضطرد وقله
المساحات لاستيعاب هذا الاكتظاظ السكاني
ما يدفع المسؤولين عن القطاع الى ضروره
التفكير في استغلال مساحات فارغه لكنها
قريبه من الحدود مع اسرائيل لرفع المعاناه
عن كاهل الفقراء في غزه الذين يحلمون بسكن
لائق وانساني لاولادهم يعني حقيقه ان يعني
قطاع غزه منطقه ضيقه وهناك انفجار سكاني
حادث وهو بحاجه الى حلول سياسيه يجب ان
يتم توسيع القطاع يجب استعاده اراضينا
المحتله حتى يعيش ابناء قطاع غزه يعني
بسلام وامان
تعيش ام عمر واكثر من مئه اسره فلسطينيه
منذ سنوات مع اطفالها وسط مقبره الشيخ
شعبان ولم يشفع لها ضيق الحال حيث تلاحقها
السلطات لاخلاء المكان
الحل في وضع اولويات للشعب
الفلسطيني اولا نحن بحاجه الى مشاريع
اسكانيه نحن بحاجه الى مشاريع تعليميه نحن
بحاجه الى مشاريع صحيه هذه ثلاث ركائز
اساسيه يجب ان تبنى عليها اولويات الجهات
الحاكم في القطاع غزه يعني يجب ان يكون
هناك تحرك باتجاه حل هذه القضايا ولكن من
الواضح ان ممكن تكون نتيجه للحصار
الاسرائيلي له بعض التاثيرات السلبيه على
على اقتصاد قطاع غزه لكن انا بعتقد انه
عدم تطرق هذه الحكومات
لمتابعه بعض القضايا الجوهريه وبالتحديد
سنتعلق بالاسكان مع الجهات المانحه انا
بعتقد هو السبب اللي فاق من مشكله السكن
في قطاع غزه بهذا الحال
الحصار الاسرائيلي والوضع المعيشي الصعب
لحياه السكان في غزه زاد من ارتفاع نسبه
الجريمه في المجتمع واتخذت بعض عصابات
الجريمه المنظمه وتجار المخدرات من
المقابر مقرا لممارسه نشاطهم الاجرامي ما
يعرض حياه الاهالي للخطر يعني
يمه يمه في زلمه بيجري ورايا في السكينه
بسكر
يعني الوضع الوضع هنا القعده هان بحد
ذاتها خطر هم بيجوا بالهم الاشياء بس ما
بنعرف شو بدهم مخدرات واشياء زي هيك بس
احنا بنعرفهمش احنا نفسنا
بيجوا مكممين احيانا في وجوههم
يبيع المخدرات على باب ضربك اطلع اتكلم يا
راجل اللي يقول لي سكينه اللي يقول لي بدي
احط لك شفره في وجهك اللي بقول لي انخمد
وحط راسك وما لكش دعوه في الناس ولادي
بيطلعوا يا عمي صرت اربعه الليل والنهار
اظلني على اولادي خايف بطلعهمش من قلب
الدار يا اما هيك شفت بنفسك غير هيك
جهازي مكافحه المخدرات في غزه يقوم بحملات
مداهمه بين فتره واخرى للحد من خطر انتشار
افه المخدرات رغم ضعف الامكانيات التي
تستوجب توفرها اجهزه فحص للكشف عن
المخدرات ومراقبه مستمره لكل الانفاق
وتجار المخدرات
ومروجيها وغالبا ما يكون حجم الكميات
المهربه صغيرا مما يصعب من مهمه اصطيادها
احنا للاسف الشديد على مدار 15 سنه من
الانقسام و15 سنه من الحصار الشديد
والحروب المتكرره بدات تظهر في المجتمع
الفلسطيني ظواهر لم يكن لم تكن سابقا
اطلاقا في تاريخ المجتمع الفلسطيني في
قطاع غزه بدانا نشهد ارتفاع في وتيره
الجريمه بدانا نشهد ارتفاع في عدد
المتسولين بدانا نشهد بدانا نشهد شيء غريب
جدا انه بعض الناس تسكن في المقابر
من يضيق الخناقه على الاخر ساكنوا القبور
ام الموتى ماساه انسانيه في قطاع يحاصره
الاحتلال من جهه والصراع الاخوه يزيد من
معاناه شعبه من جهه اخرى
مسؤوليه تقع على عاتق حكومه رام الله
حماس بالتساوي لان الحكومه رام الله هي
مسؤوله ايضا عن مواطنين قطاع غزه كما هي
حكومه حماس في قطاع غزه فهي مسؤوله ايضا
عن توفير
متطلبات ابناء قطاع غزه وبالتالي لا يمكن
لنا باي حال من الاحوال ان نعفي حكومه رام
الله عن المسؤوليه عن كل الازمات التي
تحدث في قطاع غزه كما ايضا نحمل حماس
المسؤوليه عن عن الكثير من هذه الازمات
ما حدش دور عنا بالمره كتير نشدنا وكتير
جريت وكثير عملته على الفاضي مش قادر انا
اكثر من هيك يعني ناس كتير يعني عندهم
عندهم حاجات كثيره طلع لهم وراحوا قدموا
بيطلع لهم بعد شهر وشهرين واحنا لليوم
المعاناه من حرب 2014 بهدلنا في الحرب
وبعديها قال لنا سجلوا تعالوا وجريت ورحت
ما حدش طلع لنا قال لنا كل كل حكوا لي حين
يجي عليك حنيجي عليكم ما حدش اجانا ولا
احنا عشان الفقراء يعني ما حدش بتطلع لنا
احلام وفقراء غزه ومناشداته من اجل توفير
سكن لائق مازالت حبيسه جدران المقبره على
تجد صدى لدى المسؤولين عن القطاع من اجل
ايجاد حل جذري ينقذ اطفالهم من الضياع
ولكن لا حلول في الافق القريب
[موسيقى]